Can we that was the only questions we had come in you didn't have a lot of questions that came in so
This could be a short medium. Let's you guys have some more questions. Can we measure the amount of glutamate?
In the blood
No, you can't so
Remember there's a difference between glutamate and glutamine
So glutamate is the need to ask it and it converts to glutamate
It doesn't just convert to glutamate
Glutamate just like any other amino acid
Is used to build proteins that your body you need to eat proteins in
order for your body to break them down through the digestive process so that you can then absorb
the amino acids
So that your body can use those amino acids to make different proteins and enzymes. So
It ends. I was actually a protein. So you need amino acids in order to make those
So you eat protein in order to
You know obtain amino acids so that you can make proteins
Now you use them to make other things too. Glutamate is an amino acid that is also converted to glutamate
on the
the GAD genetic pathways through the GAD pathways
So if a person has some defects in those GAD pathways they tend to convert glutamate to glutamate more readily and
then
It can be a problem. It can be with some people
So glutamate is not a feeder of cancer glutamate
doesn't
Is it not a factor in the cancer?
Picture whatsoever
But glutamate is a factor in other things glutamate as a neurotransmitter
functions as an excitatory neurotransmitter and in the brain
it can lead to
emotional issues. So people with OCD issues people
That tend to get fixated on something and can't get off of it
People with anxiety issues have excess amounts of glutamate in the blood
Now again, why would a person have excess amounts of glutamate in the blood and in the brain?
Well, it's that they may have that genetic defect on the GAD genes and they make too much glutamate
And they don't get rid of glutamates very quickly
Or they may consume glutamates in themselves
Not glutamate, but glutamate
So where would you get glutamates? Well, our food industry purposely puts glutamates in food
Because it's an excitatory neurotransmitter. So that's the science of food
So they purposely use glutamates like modusodium glutamate
in order to
excite your brain when you eat that. So when you when your tongue encounters
MSG which is glutamate modusodium glutamate
It fires an excitatory response to the brain. It makes you think that that food tastes better
Remember, taste is completely a function of receptors on your tongue that are firing back to your brain
So that's why you can learn to
Like the taste of something over time. It's a really a function of your brain
so
But when you have glutamate on your tongue, it's going to fire an excitatory response to your brain
And it's going to wake up your brain and it'd be like this like little firecracker in your brain
And you're going to go, oh, that's good. That tastes good
And you're going to want more of that food and you're going to buy more of that food. That's why you'll
You're addicted to eating Doritos and you buy them all the time because they have modusodium glutamates in there
Now that damages your brain when you're constantly excited your brain because of
You need too many glutamates or
Having defects where you just produce more glutamates. It can it can damage your brain. It can damage those
Neural pathways in your brain and basically burn them out. That's the problem with
modusodium glutamate. It can lead to
To damages in your brain and inflammatory processes in your brain and
You know microglial primate and antibody and antibody production of neural antibodies and
autoimmune issues in the brain
so
But glutamates really don't tie in to cancer
Glutamine ties into cancer because it can be a
Driver it can be a fuel source for a cell metabolic process, but
Not so much glutamates
What do you recommend for carbohydrates daily intake with cancer patients?
um, so
You don't it's I wouldn't
You know, there are like addkins diets where you're really measuring your grams of carbohydrates on a daily basis and you're trying to
Trying to get those grams of carbohydrates down
um, and I guess you can do that if you want
um, the um
I would much rather have you just if you want to do that
You'd rather have you look at grams of
sugar and measure that or better yet maybe because it's actually how your body uses carbohydrates
That's really important is to measure blood glucose. So get a glucometer
Um, so getting a glucometer and testing your blood glucose in a fasting state
So you're tested in the morning before you eat anything you have any anything all night long you're in a
10 or 12 hour fast and you do a finger prick and you measure your glucose
The goal for a cancer patient is you really want to get that
Into the 70s. Now I've stated multiple times that sometimes that's really hard to do but um, I have um
other members home page
I have a monitoring sheet PDF that you can download and you can keep track of your glucose levels that way if you get yourself a glucometer
And I have some information written about that that will explain it even more
So instead of looking at daily carbohydrate intake I'd rather have you more focused on getting your
glucose levels down
Because carbohydrates are split into simple and complex carbohydrates and it's actually a sliding scale
And then it gets even more confusing because there's a um
Let's call the glycemic index and how fast things actually break down into sugar
And we've often said that you don't want to eat like potatoes and rice because it breaks down to sugar
But if you cook potatoes and you put them in the refrigerator
Already cooked it becomes a more stable carbohydrate and then you eat it the next day the glycemic index is much better
And it does not break down into sugar quite as fast so it gets complicated with um
How you break it down also gets complicated and others and supplements that you're taking if you're taking
Burberry it can help reduce blood sugar levels and help reduce them that
Uh glycemic load on your um
And prevent glucose from being too available to be used as a cancer fuel too
So there's different nutritional things
Um that make that a difference too and it's even more complicated because if you're eating
even sugar with
A protein and with a fat then you tend not to break that sugar down quite as quickly and you might not absorb much much
And you might have a less effect on your blood glucose level because it's really all about not just what you take in
But it's what how it affects
Um the cell so it's a it's really what circulated in your blood. So measuring your blood glucose is a better way to look at that
I noticed the sedimentation rate is not an item on the blood work you have
compiled and rubah
I know that is a blood test that nasha winters recommends for surveillance is that important to track um
If there are a couple other things that I do want to add to that
Um test that I haven't done yet and that is one of them
Uh is that really important to track
Not necessary every blood test has a level of importance to track with that that has to do
with ademia issues um and um I may add that to that test
So um if you want to weigh a couple of days before you order that maybe i'll get that done tomorrow
I know you've addressed celery juice before
My teen son struggles with acne and I began last
began have
began last week I assume taking it
One time I used well-washed
non-organic celery and within an hour he was very exhausted and I became extremely dizzy
Neither of us had had anything else the dizziness is better
But not god and I have extreme brain fog memory issues as well
Would you think this is a reaction to metals or pesticides or something else in that celery
If not then what if so what should we do
Also are you aware if celery juice has been effective for cancer acne or other
morbidities that it is claimed to help
So um yeah, it's really hard to say that um
You know your symptoms were a direct result
Drinking that celery juice that it could have been something in that
um a clue gives us that
Both you and your son may have felt similar after drinking it that gives you a clue that
It's you know a greater possibility that that was it
What could have possibly been in a non-organic celery juice that it could have caused problems
um
I don't know that I have to look at the recent dirty dozen list
If celery is often sprayed um as a gardener
I'm trying to think why you would spray celery
uh
With a pesticide
Because I don't think you know there's very many pests that um
That um you know bother celery
However, definitely if it's not organic it they used different fertilizers
um to
To make it grow celery is a not a super fast growing vegetable
so um
Yeah, it's really hard to know what could have caused that
Um, it could literally could have become dizzy or exhausted if that was the only thing you drank like you were on a
Some sort of celery juice fast or something and you that's the only thing you that you drank
um
So christy said celery is on the dirty dozen list
So yeah, and it anything is possible if it was if it's a um
Uh, it was sprayed with roundup or something like that if it's on the dirty dozen list
That's most of the things that the dirty dozen list were sprayed with pesticides like that
and herbicides
Then um certainly an herbicide could cause issues like that
Anything that crosses the blood brain barrier could cause inflammation in the brain if it gets worse is that if you already have
um a history of
Braid inflammatory issues meaning you already you had concussions in the past you already have
known
um
Other things that have caused symptoms
Braid upper-modular type symptoms
That would give you clues that you that you probably already know that you have some primed microglial cells
Um, or worse if you have done a syrex array 7x which measures antibodies for
Neural tissue and it was and you had any positives of that
um
then
You then anything that could cause inflammation the brain is going to make that worse
So it's going to take
You know, it can take weeks for that to calm back down
How do you help calm that down if that's the scenario that you have to use flavonoids that we've talked about
You know multiple times go back and watch the
The video called neuroinflammation. It's on the blog
If you just search neuroinflammation on the blog you'll see it's about a half-hour video that explains
Microglial priming and the things that you don't want to do for that
um
Certainly people that are more sensitive. Why doesn't everybody on the I know people that never eat organic foods
Well, they might not be as sensitive to these pesticides and things like that. They may have an intact blood brain barrier
um
And or they you know have
Symptoms of dizziness and lightheadedness and that's just normal for them so they'd ever think about it
I don't know there's all sorts of reasons for that
but um
Certainly if you have a damaged blood brain barrier and you're exposed to things like that they're going to cross that barrier
keto mojo sells a monitor that measures both glucose and ketones
Then we'll track automatically in their app monitors about 45 dollars, I think
App is free
um
Yeah, you can track ketones as well and we're talking back about tracking
carbohydrates and you see it in glucomet or to track glucose
um
You have to look at the cost of the strips because usually the ketone
monitors the strips cost a little bit more and it just depends on what you want to invest in that so
Uh, I just checked 20 23 less not on either dirty doesn't or clean 15 so if it's not on the clean 15 then
You know that it is sprayed with something
Even though it might not be heavily sprayed with something
um
Thank you guys for doing that work
I had six ultrasound panels done on swollen lymph nodes in my groins our pits and neck looking for residual cancer last week
The scans came back as oversized nodes in groins, but the conclusion was benign in all well praise god for that
The oncologists want to biopsy the nodes in the groin in the armpits if not cancerous
The oncologist wants to do surgery of my neck and remove the lymph nodes
As a precaution and to test them what are your thoughts
Well in one sense, I would agree with your oncologist that well we don't know until we get a you know a complete pathology report
Maybe we take the tissue out and spit it onto a slide and look for cancer cells
There could be cancer cells there
Well, I know but what are we gonna do to remove all your organs to do that same thing?
I mean, you have to you have to draw the line somewhere or what
How invasive you want to get
So if not invasive tests show a low
Possibility of
Cancerous tumors there then I would be inclined to just say okay. Let's not to get too cut happy
Easy your lymph nodes. They can be
So lymph nodes can enlarge when you're dealing with an infection
Lived nodes can enlarge when you're dealing with a lot of toxins
Lived nodes can enlarge when you're dealing with a lot of things that are going through them
So what goes through the lymph nodes anything that's cleared out of the tissues
Upstream from that lymph node
So things don't get cleared out of the tissues magically. They have to go through your open-ended lymph
papillaries. So your lymph vessels
pick up
fluid and waste in the tissues and it drains down back to your
Your venous system which then goes through
Eventually the liver again and it's detoxified through the liver detox pathways. So
That's how we get toxins out of our tissues whether those toxins are
From you know things that we're exposed to
Topically or whether things that get dumped from the bloodstream that we adjusted or
or from surgical procedures that were
distilled to that
lymph node
You know
Chemicals that you know chemical procedures like chemotherapy that have to go through that all those kind of things. So
Um, I mean, it's up to you. I know there's a lot of people in the world that they just will just do everything that their oncologist says because they won't
They think that's the best chance to survive. So they'll just go and have all those things removed and
You know some people may I'm not saying some people don't have good results with that
But if there's a lot of people that have bad results that that too
I think you have to make the decision to draw your line and have some sense of
Conservativeness in allowing, you know, the next procedures
The nodes in my deck where the tumors where have much calcification can you explain why
And what this is so calcification of lymph nodes
um can be just the the nodal tissue
Uh uptaking minerals and calcium because of
protective measure of somewhat some sort
um and
Becoming overly toxic because they've been
Filtering too many toxins. Yeah, I don't fully understand the physiology of that I'd have to look that up
Is there danger with doing biopsies only they said they would be small needles
Well, there's danger of doing anything
But is that less invasive?
Obviously, they're going to surgically removing it to test it. Oh, I guess it was all nice and clean
Well now that we surgically removed it you can't put it back. So
um
Yeah, it'd be much less invasive, you know, you're talking about your invasiveness
What is doing nothing and what is um
Next is doing nothing but getting it tested on a regular basis the next would be
Maybe doing a biopsy and going from there. So
I know these are these are tough decisions when you know, you're pushed in one direction. So
um
And you you feel a lot of pressure in your decision-making process
But you're just gonna stand your grow to go. Okay, I want to be wise about this and
And try to make the best decision. I'm not gonna just follow one person's advice
biopsy would be the groin and the armpit surgical would be in the neck
My original plan included a low histamine diet and then my genetics came back then I had an issue with
The genes associated with histobines
I have been on a histobines scavenger product as a result
I wasn't given a DAO A-D-A-O supplement though
So does that mean I have the D-A-O enzymes for why would I have histamine issues
So you have some several gene families for histobines you have the D-A-O gene families and you have the H-N-T gene families
And actually there was more racially discovered another gene family. I can't remember the name of it
I have to do with histobines um
D-A-O gene family was the first one discovered and that makes the D-A-O gene or D-A-O enzyme
the diving
oxidase enzyme that breaks down histamine
Now that is made only in the gut so you use
If you took a D-A-O supplement so you could actually take D-A-O that's our
histoclear supplement is the D-A-O enzyme
Now if you take that that's not something you absorb
that enzyme stays in your gut
in that um so it will so a person that would take the D-A-O enzyme is a person who has this horrible
inflammatory process going on in the intestinal tract
um and they'll take that to calm that down for a period of time
Another group that might take that are people that
um know that they react to foods that have histobines in it but they're
taken as a precautionary measure because they're going out or they're going to eat that food
um uh some people react to uh have a huge histamine reaction to alcohol per se
but they're going out to a party and they know they're going to drink that you know gin and tonics
and they don't want to have this huge histamine reaction so they take
several D-A-O enzymes before they drink the alcohol or before they eat that food
um D-A-O enzymes do not get rid of histobines in the tissues
and only would get rid of histobines that are produced in the gut or that are consumed
by the person and and then spill you know have this inflammatory response in the gut
so we don't recommend D-A-O enzymes typically to a person with cancer
you're trying to get rid of the histobines in the tissues that is the H-N-T-G
so even if you have a lot of defects in the D-A-O enzyme R-D-A-O genes
doesn't mean you should take that enzyme
it's actually it's a pretty expensive product too so I don't really recommend it that often
um histobines scavenger is a combination of different nutrients that help get rid of
histobines in the tissues so um and those are produced those are gotten rid of
through the H-N-T-G-D not the D-A-O genes so that's the difference with that try to get rid of
histobines in the tissue you take histobines scavenger you take clear hist
or you know or certain type products different things that will that will be rid of histobine
response in the tissues themselves when do you post zoom recordings um usually within it gets
posted within minutes it takes me it takes a few minutes to download the recording and then to
upload it into YouTube so it's just as fast as it takes to do that I did check EWG before using the
regular salary but didn't find it I thought I've read that if it's either it's uneven list it's
somewhere in between possibly safe yes that's correct in the salary juice book it says
regular is fine if washed well I wouldn't dare do it again and remember to that um you know remember
these fields that might be sprayed um it's a tractor driving down the field and they have this
great big apparatus in the back that is sprayed um and then they turn a quarter at the end of the field
and you think the product at those quarters probably get like four times the dose you know
when it's when they don't turn off the sprayer to turn the corner you know what I mean it can be
something weird like that that you just got a you know a stalk of salary that was you know infested
if that's the right terminology with with some sort of toxin and and if you went to the same store
about another stalk is the next day you know if they'd go through it that fast it could be completely
a different dose I mean there's no way that unless you have your own organic chemistry lab that you're
going to be able to test you know each peach of food that you're going to you know cook for your family
to see the doses of glyphosate or whatever you're looking for in that so it's you it you're kind of
hit miss and the truth is you can be exposed to the stuff with organic stuff there's cross
contamination sometimes these fields are very far apart that they're contaminated with or it could
be something completely different than it was contaminated with who knows or it could not maybe not
even be the salary itself so oh there's another thing too you can actually have antibodies to salary
so running the array Syrex array 10 I've had people that have antibodies to salary so they're
going to have an inflammatory spot response by eating salary whether it's organic or not organic
so that's a possibility or you could just had you know what inflammatory spots because it's
something else that was going on and you're got you know there's a lot of possibilities
um we don't want to completely jump to the conclusions that we were talking about so we just don't
know everything um as far as the benefits of salary juice yeah there can be benefits to juicing
different vegetables um but um they just be careful going on a specific diet that's restricted
other foods and other nutrients to you're better off getting as many different foods and food
groups in your system as as possible that's going to be the best thing to support your got biome and
the rest of your biome um is to have a variety of different foods so I've been told binders should not
be taken closer than two hours at either end of other supplements do you agree yeah I think you should
be taking binders on a relatively empty stomach okay with that I think we're going to close tonight
thanks for being on and um oh that we're all praying for you and hope that you're praying for each
other as well um and um if you do need any follow up contacts um make sure you just make an appointment
all right bye bye everybody